[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROHIT KAPOOR: Good
afternoon, Googlers.
My name is Rohit Kapoor,
and I am a business manager
on the global business team.
I'm sorry.
This is a fanboy moment
for me right now,
so I'm going to be
a little nervous.
It gives me immense
pleasure today
to host this talk with the king
of bhangra, Malkit Singhji.
And if time permits, we may get
a little glimpse of his magic,
with the tumbi.
Just to give you some
background about him,
he has been a great ambassador
for the Punjabi and North
Indian music and culture
throughout the globe.
He has made his community proud.
He was awarded
with an MBE, which
is the Member of the Order
of the British Empire Award,
by the Queen herself.
He was also recognized
for his work
by the City of Los Angeles for
the Indian community service.
Today, we are privileged
and honored to have
the man himself, the bhangra
king, the golden star, Malkit
Singh, with me.
Please welcome him on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALKIT SINGH: Thank you.
Thank you.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
MALKIT SINGH: [LAUGHS]
ROHIT KAPOOR: [NON-ENGLISH].
Welcome to Google.
MALKIT SINGH: Thank you.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
Please have a seat.
MALKIT SINGH: Thanks.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Let's
get this started.
This is your first time
on the Google campus?
MALKIT SINGH: Yeah, this
is my first time to Google.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Well, your fans
in the room and on YouTube.
MALKIT SINGH: Thank you, ji.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Thank you.
ROHIT KAPOOR: We're
actually fortunate, very
fortunate to have you here.
MALKIT SINGH: Thank you.
ROHIT KAPOOR: So what's
your favorite memory
of being in the Bay Area?
MALKIT SINGH: I perform in
the area like in San Francisco
and [INAUDIBLE] and a couple--
you know, a show in here
as well.
And so every time [NON-ENGLISH],,
because every time sold out
show.
And when you do the concert,
it's like [NON-ENGLISH] fans
[NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR: And the
Indian community--
[INAUDIBLE] strong Indian
community in the Bay Area
[INAUDIBLE] fan following and
the performances that you give.
It just has a big impact.
Social media, as well,
goes really crazy on that.
MALKIT SINGH: Oh, these days,
social media, number one,
[NON-ENGLISH].
You know, channel.
Before, when we played like we
used to play in San Francisco,
it's no media, no newspaper,
no television, [NON-ENGLISH]..
But these days,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
A lot of Indian
ROHIT KAPOOR: [NON-ENGLISH].
MALKIT SINGH: And a
[NON-ENGLISH] Indians
[NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALKIT SINGH: Yes, yes.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
People who matter to you,
[NON-ENGLISH] family,
[NON-ENGLISH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
I was only four, five-year-old
kid [NON-ENGLISH]..
I used to copy [NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR: [NON-ENGLISH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
And then start in school,
then after that, college,
[NON-ENGLISH].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
But I never thought I could
make with professional artists
[NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR: The concept
or the inspiration--
[NON-ENGLISH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
At that time, more mystique.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And then as he
started [NON-ENGLISH]..
So college life [NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
Malkit Singh, superstar,
[NON-ENGLISH]..
MALKIT SINGH: [NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]??
MALKIT SINGH: Sometime I
think, man, so lucky, man.
I'm so lucky, because when
I was in college time,
all of Punjab knows
[NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],, because
we have to wear folk dress.
And we used to--
you can use only
three instruments,
like [NON-ENGLISH]
dhol, tumbi, harmonium.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And when I [INAUDIBLE]
school, college [INAUDIBLE]
competition.
[NON-ENGLISH] entered
college competition.
So [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So then after that man,
do [INAUDIBLE],, radio,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR: [NON-ENGLISH]?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR: Tumbi?
MALKIT SINGH: Oh, yes.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],, please.
MALKIT SINGH: Ah.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALKIT SINGH: [LAUGHS]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
This is my [NON-ENGLISH].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
English, which we can
say, [NON-ENGLISH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: [NON-ENGLISH].
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
You can say one string guitar.
Punjabi, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] first song
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
The music.
ROHIT KAPOOR: The
music [NON-ENGLISH]..
What's coming up?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
But [NON-ENGLISH].
Millions [NON-ENGLISH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[LAUGHING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Golden stars.
University [NON-ENGLISH]
gold medal,
university folk song
competition [NON-ENGLISH]..
So [NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH],, was this your
first song ever that you
recorded, or
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]??
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Then all [NON-ENGLISH]
music [NON-ENGLISH] produce
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
The people are probably
thinking, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
BBC TV [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
English [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
They start like Punjabi
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] English.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] that
I'm 86 with just the first
time recording [NON-ENGLISH]..
At that time, England, which
was no Indian music, a musician,
or anything.
Nobody [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And first made recording
are done in five hours,
[NON-ENGLISH],, 14
songs [NON-ENGLISH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: 14
songs [INAUDIBLE]..
MALKIT SINGH: [INAUDIBLE]
song [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
So then [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
The bhangra music
start from there.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH: Because
the [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
We need something [NON-ENGLISH].
So [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] 86
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALKIT SINGH: First
million [NON-ENGLISH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] 86, then.
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
Thank you so much.
Now let's move on
to the song that
helped not only you, but
the entire Punjabi music
shine globally--
"Tutak Tutak Tutiya."
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
The lyrics [NON-ENGLISH]
interesting.
English word [NON-ENGLISH].
MALKIT SINGH: Actually,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] East
Indian or [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Because then when
I move in England,
men used to like
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
listening song, [NON-ENGLISH]
audience [NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
People are so hungry for bhangra
music, dance [NON-ENGLISH]..
So they wanted to hear
something [INAUDIBLE] dance,
because everybody busy there.
They're all
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
So then [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So then as [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And it's very romantic song
this is, because in Punjab,
it's three gold [NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
And [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]??
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
All day, look.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And it's a very romantic
time to [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
That time [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Look.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So it's a romantic song.
Hey, [NON-ENGLISH], look.
[LAUGHTER]
Hey, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
accidentally
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]??
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] .
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]??
MALKIT SINGH: In
'90 [NON-ENGLISH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: '90
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
Because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Language, [NON-ENGLISH]
different language
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Again, same movie.
You want to say something.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
I have a story to share as well.
Back in my childhood,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
Informally, [NON-ENGLISH].
Formally, [NON-ENGLISH].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
So then people gave me that
honor, King of Bhangra.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
What led to this transition
from bhangra, peppy songs
to such a soulful,
emotional song?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Listening song
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] family
song [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
You know, in the
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I think when you are
away from your country,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
You miss your family.
And on that time,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
When we leave this album,
I want to make
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Because [NON-ENGLISH] listening
song [NON-ENGLISH] audience
[NON-ENGLISH].
So then [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
because I was feeling
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So then we shot the
video in Bombay,
and [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Because [INAUDIBLE]
meaning [NON-ENGLISH],,
because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
When you wave from your
house, [INAUDIBLE] always miss
your family or especially
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
feeling [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Five-star, seven-star
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Because of [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So that's where you
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
You just mentioned you
felt bad that you were away
from home, which is why you
kind of wrote these songs.
MALKIT SINGH: Yes.
ROHIT KAPOOR: What's special
about [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]??
MALKIT SINGH: Same thing
again, because the man
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
And sometimes in hotel--
English film, "Bend It like
Beckham," [NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR: I think that
was also a great honor
to be included in
an English movie.
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: So you just
mentioned [NON-ENGLISH]
settling in England
and everything.
But then you went on
to serve the community
so much that you were
awarded with an MBE award
by the Queen herself.
MALKIT SINGH: Yeah.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
The Queen never talks to
anyone while giving the award.
When you received that award,
when you received that letter
first, and you accepted,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
and what was going
through your mind?
MALKIT SINGH: Same thing.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] timing.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
10 Downing Street
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
But [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So then after that,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
May the 7th, 2008.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Anybody [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
tuxedo [NON-ENGLISH]..
Black suit, black shoe,
shine [NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Indian song
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
So I thought I should wear
something [NON-ENGLISH] Indian
clothes [NON-ENGLISH].
But I don't know.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
But I don't think [NON-ENGLISH].
Buckingham Palace,
Queen [NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So [NON-ENGLISH],, she gave
me the award of [INAUDIBLE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
You look like maharajah.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Maharajah.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
You're wearing on the stage as
well, so [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH] traditional
[NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
because [NON-ENGLISH] Indian
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] BBC News
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
She [INAUDIBLE] said to me,
"You look like maharajah."
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Honestly, that kind of a
comment coming from Her Highness
herself, queen
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
you look like a maharajah.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Professional
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Guinness
Book of Records,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: Biggest selling
bhangra artist in the world--
Guinness Book of
World Record holder.
[APPLAUSE]
Fantastic.
MALKIT SINGH: So Queen
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
The next day, I went to
India [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Because every weekend,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
And another thing--
ROHIT KAPOOR: Absolutely.
MALKIT SINGH: But when you're
performing on wedding party,
private party,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] security
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Another thing-- we need
to [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]..
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH] party,
wedding parties especially,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHING]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Another thing--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Because sometimes,
[LAUGHTER]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH: And when
[NON-ENGLISH] online
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
The third thing--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
the regeneration,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
They always said
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
He's my [INAUDIBLE].
He's my [NON-ENGLISH].
He's my uncle [NON-ENGLISH].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR: Family,
the introduction
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
Now that we're talking
about the thought process,
and when you write a
song and create a song,
I think half of the world still
doesn't know Punjabi music
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
They start singing as well.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Golden
Star [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
awarded with a star
in the Birmingham
[INAUDIBLE] of Stars.
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
I mean you've represented the
entire Punjabi-North Indian
community throughout the world.
You've made us proud.
How do you manage to stay
so humble and down to earth/
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
I'm not [NON-ENGLISH] represent
only Punjabi [INAUDIBLE]
Punjabi communities.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Indian
represent [NON-ENGLISH]..
I perform in 54 countries.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Wow.
MALKIT SINGH: And
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
People call [NON-ENGLISH]
Indian show.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Thank you for
correcting me on that.
MALKIT SINGH: [NON-ENGLISH].
ROHIT KAPOOR: I'm so glad
you corrected me on that.
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: Thank you.
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Indian show happening in here.
And it's Indian night.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
54 countries play
[NON-ENGLISH] live.
And [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
When an Englishman
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
All-time favorite
song [NON-ENGLISH]??
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Do a meaningful song
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Line
of duty.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] living
away from his or her home,
when they listen to this song,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
ROHIT KAPOOR: YouTube
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH: Technical jargon.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Technical
[NON-ENGLISH]..
Honestly, [INAUDIBLE]
the audience.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
superstar [NON-ENGLISH]----
how we discovered
these songs is YouTube.
And what do you think
about this as a platform
for not only the listeners,
but also for the singers
these days?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
And at that time, no
video, no channel,
nothing [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Or 31st, New Year Day--
New Year Eve Day.
The New Year Eve
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] New Year
Day [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR: Amazing,
amazing [INAUDIBLE]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
But I think we
are short of time,
though [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
rapid fire question
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
I'll say a couple of words,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] the first
thing that comes to your mind.
Favorite food?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] light
food, actually.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Chinese,
Indian [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Favorite place in the world?
MALKIT SINGH: Man, being
all over the world.
[NON-ENGLISH] Singapore
[NON-ENGLISH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: Singapore?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR: Discipline
[INAUDIBLE] over there.
Favorite venue to perform at?
MALKIT SINGH: Favorite venue?
New York Lincoln Center.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Audience [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Any upcoming
project that you are
excited about in
the near future?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
or at least 23 albums.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Oh, wow.
MALKIT SINGH: And now it's
like a single [INAUDIBLE]..
And I think really is
the last album we're
supposed to release as CD.
But [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] on a
single [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
So next project
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
ROHIT KAPOOR:
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Next month [INAUDIBLE] release.
ROHIT KAPOOR: They are so
excited about that and looking
forward to your new
songs, [NON-ENGLISH]..
MALKIT SINGH: [NON-ENGLISH]
heavy music and different
styles.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Because as you start
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Nowadays there is
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
ROHIT KAPOOR: [SINGING]
What did you say?
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Remix first time
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
It's too much modern
So I don't want to
come in the video.
But [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
That was a fantastic--
MALKIT SINGH: That's my song.
And remix starts from there.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
But for a shortage of time, I
know, but [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
They would love to know
so much more about you.
MALKIT SINGH: Thank you.
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
Google-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Thank you so much,
again, [NON-ENGLISH],,
for joining us today.
Again, this is a
lifetime moment for us
that we will remember for
a long, long, long time.
MALKIT SINGH: Thank
you very much.
It's a great honor.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR: Google
[NON-ENGLISH]..
MALKIT SINGH: Google
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
Thank you very much.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
ROHIT KAPOOR:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
MALKIT SINGH:
ROHIT KAPOOR: When you
joined us today here.
MALKIT SINGH: Thank
you very much.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Thank you so much.
MALKIT SINGH: Thank you.
ROHIT KAPOOR: Give
it up for the man
himself, the Bhangra King,
Golden Star, Malkit Singh.
[APPLAUSE]
MALKIT SINGH: Thank you.